hello reject nation hired exec nation
presents drag here and I'm John Humphrey
have you seen season three of black
mayor I haven't seen all of it I've seen
selective's I've seen the first season
in the second season I didn't see the
one that actually debuted on Netflix
today's video is brought to you by
Stardust app start us I'm sure you guys
first talked a lot about it officially
part of the reject community we love
using it guys
30-second reactionary film TV show or a
trailer and speaking of Netflix John oh
my goodness that's a film TV show or
trailer I just covered and John covered
one of all of the episodes of The
Punisher on Netflix you know what I have
to catch up with black mirror I've seen
the first two seasons they're probably
gonna do star dust reactions I'm black
mirror especially when the fourth season
comes out so guys download the app and
follow us at the real rejects because
we're almost at 1,500 followers you know
there's me about us how this video goes
up will already be there
the show doesn't make me feel good it is
hard to watch it's like it's really well
done gripping but later you're like yeah
but at the same time every episode Anson
you're like oh then I'm gonna watch it
third season everyone says it's the best
black mirror a crocodile
what is your technology with crocodiles
now what if what how would technology
affect the crocodile hey shout out today
patron the day shots are in Raj Krishna
these can be subjective
they may not be totally accurate and
they're often emotional I don't remember
anything it's a total blank picture what
you saw did you see the vehicle that hit
the pedestrian I didn't see the actual
crash do you mind if I ask you a few
questions
no sir do this accesses your memories of
what happened
[Music]
that stuff is private self oh my oh my
yeah it's great about this show you can
do a trailer for every episode yeah yeah
is there another one out there I don't
see on the Netflix channel art angel
[Music]
ever than 2,000 years old and I remember
when we used talked about the door this
is what you really miss we've been
hearing there's really inspirational
[Music]
oh no that does not look like a good
situation no okay see the first one
crocodile reminds me of that one episode
that really stood out to me of that
couple who has the memory brain Stan
yeah and I'm like okay well this is semi
familiar territory it's a little
different using the concept of memories
and going yeah mind again yeah and kind
of like a detective investigation type
of vibe look cooler it didn't look as
like is gonna be haunting yeah that was
like knowing what black where does this
is gonna end terribly yeah I'm doing to
the children yeah wanting a control or a
kid you know when you people talk about
putting chips and your kids yeah way you
can flick try to hit the red button and
then boom next
think that's a thing you're doing that
now that's a thing oh boy today it's a
great way to keep somebody in line it's
so conflicting because it's such good
television but I don't know are you guys
like that do you guys get the highway of
lag mirror are we the only ones it makes
you yeah I got a I would be curious to
know how y'all feel because it is a hard
show to watch I couldn't ever been Jim
yeah I watched two episodes back-to-back
I had a migraine and I wanted to keep
watching yeah the idea of addiction to
technology is a big running theme of
technology getting out of hand and in
the show it's this streaming service I'm
watching I'm like I should go to bed I
don't feel good but I want to keep
watching like it's happening to me it
really is a block it's rousing it does
make you feel it is gripping yeah I mean
I love the idea that our change although
because if I have a kid I would love to
have a chip I make it so much easier
well that's so eerie I can't make a joke
about it no I can't
the key to good parenting is control Oh
imagine actually that's that's a
relationship and that's a relationship
the guy affected by drugs and technology
wasn't there Peter Dinklage movie that
was like the crocodile one rememory yeah
you're able to slowly the memory and
it's like an investigation trying to
solve something yeah yeah yeah it's at
least the vibe I got I don't know if
it's actually like a solving case type
of a deal reminded me a little strange
days that one mmm
fine you win black mirror go catch
there's one apparently though there's
one episode in season three that is not
soul-crushing and that in fact makes you
feel like that's the hard part of a
black mare is it never really ends where
characters one yeah I've heard there's
an episode that will not leave you
feeling crushed I heard there's one that
is loved thank God hopefully at the same
God we can watch that one tonight and
cry together
the irony of doing a star distri action
on an episode of black mirror another
about obsession with technology Brice's
how are killin in this episode man love
a character who deteriorates due to
obsession and that concept is brilliant
of rating people right in front of you a
downgrade upgrade there's a lot of great
messages and metaphors about not giving
into judgment of others not looking for
approval and just accepting yourself and
being honest it was great
well Niraj Krishna Raj Krishna
he's from New Jersey it doesn't exactly
work in the film business right now but
man is this guy no film this dude is
constantly recommending stuff for us to
check out on our patreon he has been a
longtime commentator as well he's a
strong supporter of the channel no Raj
he lifts a lot I am so lucky to know you
because I think you might be my only
Indian friend I have about 4 to 5 black
friends I have about 2 to 3 know about 3
gay friends I know like 1 or 2 Asian
people I'm related to Asian people and a
white people I know Hispanic max again
no I know sure me though you might share
my only male Indian friend we don't
really know that many Indian people out
here we gotta get to know more Indian
people huge I've met a lot of Indian
people and they're very friendly people
I haven't like actually developed a
strong friendship with specific
individual Indian you got to have one of
each race hey hey my buddy suit [ __ ] is
an awesome guitar player and an awesome
for these Indian I don't people who are
like half in anyway I hope you get
really involved in movie business one
day because you clearly know your film
yeah dude we love you I'm still so sorry
I couldn't meet up with you I feel
really bummed out about that but the
next time when the real rejects take New
York or New Jersey we will meet up we
will cuddle subscribe to the real
rejects please click that notification
bell you can follow dat John Humphrey
and I on Twitter and Instagram download
and follow us at the real rejects on the
Stardust app people 30-second reactions
it's a really great [ __ ]